but the Kings are within three yeah I'm
Christian
oh nice cool by Christian divine SWAT
again not a beauty right there smirking
sets a screen for young now it's
stripped cool to Scott followed the duck
by Toscano Anderson
[Applause]
that's not necessarily bad Doug you look
good yeah I appreciate it the geeks on a
beautiful theme from Toscano Anderson
now guys dropping it off it's off the
shoulder of derrickson turnover
four-on-two behind the fat fancy move in
Outland with the finish 40 to go in the
third Chicago trying to rebuild led by
as many as 19 it's up to 15 from Devon
take a [ __ ] right there turbo
penetration get to the front of the rim
and that's exactly how the Bulls have
played the baculum
Musa knock down that three-pointer on
the other end that's backed up by one
good ball moving again by Doyle first a
pass by Ruiz I love that one but Doyle
was in the ground on the pain that's the
one when you're trying to get out of the
way and there's Ruiz with the no-look
and then the pass he made four minutes
25 seconds left in his fourth quarter
[Applause]
doesn't have to give it up but he does
Brown gives it up Thomas gives it up
coaches want to see he made the right
play look at that exhale
yes let that pass like a comic book
here's a lot to look at that
anticipation and elevation from waters
to set up on Oahu jaylen Adams in
traffic lost it Hutchison ahead of the
pack a nice save it he can and it winds
up in the hands of the Koko Alexander
Walker couldn't finish blue it steals it
punches it home there's the steal and
the finish by Alexander Walker
we got some sass there and they wanted
dirt on the three
China brimming with confidence now RINO
reacted let's just watch what happens
here
good pressure by Martin but he's gonna
pull them back put them on the deck and
then eventually they're gonna get a tree
out of this mr. Martin you're gonna hear
about that later from your eyes and this
is the ensuing Brio was a terrific
defensive play by number 18 he's got the
vodka and minutes with the bulls and
hornets sherlyn leads by six second
quarter coming up from Cox pavilion and
the rebound to depths just going wrap
around behind the back pass and that's
our line ladies a jumping palace eight
Johnson cashes in making sure that the
defender committed leading it to Johnson
you got to make that wreck I've been
right through you pass like that he
didn't shoot it man you brought it back
to me
I think Alexander Walker's going to
impact to league this year I think he's
a very very good looking prospect great
back cut oh and a Throwdown from Gary
Clark here you're gonna see defense
turns his head cousins I think he
doesn't see the back cutter and then
unfortunately for old Tanner he happens
to be there too late and what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content